Miller right now
hello baby Shiloh is just hours old
my first breaths tears touches
experienced in a Health Service that has
already been responsible for her care
for months
born three weeks prematurely in the
midst of an NHS crisis to a proud but
anxious mother as an expectant mother
given everything that's going on with
the NHS at the moment were you nervous
about coming into hospital it makes you
nervous yeah because you know you're
using that service you're going to need
that service at one point in the
pregnancy so it makes you nervous you
know every time you go into the hospital
you're thinking oh is it gonna is it am
I gonna be the next person in that the
government needs to listen to the nurses
and the doctors and you know people in
the NHS and really really sort it out
no dear the newborn babies on this Ward
are under Midwife Chanel Griffith's
watchful eye like elsewhere in the NHS
her Department she says is struggling to
deal with Workforce shortages and her
expectant mothers are now older and more
high risk we need more midwives it's
very busy it seems to be getting a lot
busier
women are having babies now
um when they're a bit older which then
brings high risk more risks of them
developing complications in their
pregnancies since its creation 75 years
ago the NHS has brought more than 52
million babies into the world
Shiloh is one of Coventry Hospital's
newest patients and she can expect the
NHS to care for her throughout her
lifetime or can she with the NHS winter
crisis many questions are being asked
about the health services sustainability
and its future
heart rate at the minute is
2929 that's going through your head in
the ambulance oh who's gonna die
Edwina was born before the NHS was
created on Saturday night it saved her
life
Sky News was in the ambulance as she was
rushed to Coventry Hospital paramedics
doing everything they could to keep her
alive you were quite muddled when you
came uh to to to the cath lab because
clearly your heart rate was very low
two operations later and with a
pacemaker fitted she's almost ready to
go home
she knows her outcome could so easily
have been different God of Praise I'm
glad our lot weren't on strike I'm glad
because I don't think I'd be here to
talk to you if alot were on strike the
NHS is a life-saving life welcoming
service in crisis in need of Reform
staff and answers
so babies like Shiloh can grow up
knowing it will be there for her when
she needs it
oh she's Josh is Sky News in Coventry